[Music]
what the hell is your delay captain
waiting sir waiting for what
private dust who the hell is docs
i always dreamed about being a doctor
but uh didn't get much school
i can't stay here while all them go
fight for me
don't you figure this war is just gonna
fit in with your ideas
while everybody else is taking life i'm
going to be saving it that's going to be
my way to serve
this is a personal gift from the united
states government designed to bring
depth to the enemy i'm sorry sergeant i
can't touch a gun
she don't kill no show you know quite a
bit of killing does occur in war
private doss does not believe in
violence do not look to him to save you
on the battlefield
i don't think this is a question of
religion i think this is cowardice
i fell in love with you because you
weren't like anyone else
you're saying you could go to prison i
don't know how i'm gonna live with
myself if i don't stay true to what i
believe
with the world so set on tearing itself
apart
doesn't seem like such a bad thing to me
to want to put a little bit of it back
together
private dust you are free to run into
the hellfire of battle without a single
weapon to protect yourself
[Music]
i'm gonna get you home
there's something you gotta see i did
this
that's the car we have to go back up
tomorrow
and they're not gonna go up there
without you
[Music]
help
[Music]
please me help me get one more
help me get one more
when i was a boy heaven
was here and america
was here you could be anything you could
do anything
[Music]
i am the wrong person to have discovered
this
if you don't speak for them
who will
i found a disease that no one has ever
seen
repetitive head trauma chokes the ring
the nfl does not want to talk to you you
turned on the lights and gave their
biggest boogie man a name
you're going to war with a corporation
that owns the day of the week
no proof was presented today because
there simply isn't any
they have to listen to us this is bigger
than they are
what do you think they're doing to you
now has nothing
you have no idea how bad this could get
i have to keep going
they want you to say you made it all up
they continue to deny my work
men continue to die
[Music]
sometimes in life you're asked to leave
it alone
but sometimes you can't
who are you tell the truth
childhood truth
[Music]
how long we've known each other ken
i ever break a promise to you
i will put you in the driver's seat at
le mans
you just shut your mouth and let me do
my thing
all right
morning shelby morning molly i'm yours
i'll go to hell
and that's it folks ferrari wins the 24
hours of le mans for the fifth
consecutive year
[Applause]
mr ford ferrari has a message for you
sir what did he say
you said ford makes ugly little cars in
an ugly factory
and uh caught you fat sir
we're gonna bury ferrari at le mans
so the great carol shelby is gonna build
a car
to beat ferrari with a
forward correct and how long did you
tell them you needed
two or three hundred years 90 days
fool hates guys like us because we're
different
we heard he's difficult ken no no ken's
a puppy dog
there's a problem the computer will find
it get some scotch tape and a ball of
wool what are they doing
making your car faster
we're on the verge of something and now
you tell me that i can't have the best
man in the world behind the wheel
give me one reason why i don't fire
everyone starting with you
well sir the lighter we're faster
and that don't work we're nastier go
ahead girl
go to war you've got a planet
it's high risk i thought the whole point
was to win the damned race
if this were a beauty pageant we just
lost
looks aren't everything
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
hey
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
no no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
susan you take jerry to be your husband
what's the difference between
episcopalian and lutheran episcopalians
don't eat fish
that's pescetarianism not a religion
they're all fanatics i don't know you
you may kiss the bride
i love you
please tell me what's going on here our
group of friends has been playing the
same game of tag for 30 years
what for the entire month of may every
year
we play tag you're excuse me
you never know when someone's gonna pop
up congratulations buddy you're in
doing great anna our buddy jerry is the
best that ever played and now he wants
to retire
never been tagged just saying so who's
it you can't touch dude
let's see here we get jerry i
synchronize your watches i don't know
how to do that i don't wear a watch time
is a construct
some couples go on quizzes some couples
go camping some couples go to
strip clubs and have a gang bang
and this is just what we love this is
our gang bang wow
it seems like the game has really kept
you guys connected
all right so good to see you come on
it's been a while since we've done this
this game has given us a reason to be in
each other's lives i think your dad
would have really wanted you to be
[Music]
but ice cream what he knows i'm lactose
intolerant he's taunting me
we here highly resolve that these dead
shall not have died in vain
that this nation under god shall have a
new birth of freedom
that government of the people by the
people for the people
shall not perish from the earth
we can't tell our people they can vote
yes on abolishing slavery unless at the
same time we can tell them that you're
seeking a negotiated peace
it's either the amendment or this
confederate peace you cannot have both
how many hundreds of thousands have died
in your administration
congress must never declare equal those
who got
created unequal read the constitution
alone
we are stepped out upon the world stage
now with a fate of human dignity in our
hands
been spilled to afford us this moment
now
now now
abraham lincoln has asked us to work
with him to accomplish the death of
slavery no one's ever been
loved so much by the people don't waste
that power
this fight is for the united states of
[Music]
america
we choose to be born are we fitted to
the times we're born into
well but myself you may be
this settles the fate for all coming
time not only of the millions now
in bondage but of unborn
millions to come
shall we stop this bleeding
[Music]
give me those eyes
now do you need to give me a fossil i
will i want to be able to hold it up and
say my daddy tames the dinosaurs
we are big company millions
moving parts hey how you doing man
we all work very hard to ensure those
moving parts are functioning as a means
to very profit wind for all of us
[Music]
hey come close to the computer look at
those eyes
[Music]
that is a genuine dinosaur tooth she's
gonna
flip out good man mike
is there someone at
[Music]
mike what is that everything okay
[Music]
this is deepwater horizon what's wrong
and i will see them again do you
understand me
up and adam sean jr
you clean this room up before you come
downstairs you hear me
okay big smile chewie family let me get
it y'all
everyone thank your mother for driving
to the store and getting this thank you
mom
[Music]
he's been enrolled in seven different
institutions including
a gap of 18 months around the age of 10
when he apparently didn't attend school
at all
i tell you most kids with his background
wouldn't come within 200 miles of this
place
class this is mike orr and he's new here
so i expect you all to make him feel
welcome
hi smile it lets them know you're their
friend
i'm sure
who is that sj big mike what is he
wearing
it's below freezing do you have any
place to stay tonight
don't you dare lie to me
come on was this a bad idea
that's the big deal it's just for one
night it is just for one night right
find some time to figure out another
bedroom for you this is mine
yes sir never had one before what a room
to yourself
a baby
it's all really nice what you're doing
but don't be surprised if whether you
wake up and
he gone michael was here last night
tell him to sleep with one eye open you
threatened my son
you threatened me
[Music]
michael's grades have improved enough
that he can go out for spring
football in march
his team is your family michael when you
look at him you think of me
how you have my back are you going to
protect the family michael yes we are
sj you're going to want to get this
who's the big guy eating with your
little brother it's his big brother
i think what you're doing is so great
sandra bullock hey you're changing that
boy's life
no he's changing mine
[Applause]
the blind side
hello hey hey baby did i wake you
no i'm just at the hotel we're about to
have some breakfast
listen take it while you're doing this
it's just the lion that kills me
i need you to know that you can tell me
anything david
david yeah i got to call you right back
is everything okay yeah everything's
fine i love you bye
hey what
my name is david packhaus i'm 22 years
old and i'm an international arms dealer
six months ago i was a massage therapist
at miami beach
sorry you fell and now here i was with
my best friend from junior high
i think you should come work for me i'm
against this war this isn't about being
pro-war
this is about being pro money
how did two 20-something young men land
a 300 million
pentagon contract you told me you guys
were selling pet sheets
i also told you that we're selling other
stuff too
i thought you meant pillows america
100 million rounds of ak-47 ammo
he can fill the whole order i'm barred
from doing any business with the us
government i'm on a watch list you're on
a terrorist watch list
do you work for homeland security relax
bro this is the job to do business with
the people
the us government can't do business with
directors
we're on the verge of making 300 million
is that legal
it's not illegal
i'm not a bad man a certain situation
i have to ask myself what would a bad
man do
is this safe driving to baghdad very
safe
50 50.
what like 50 we live figures how we die
yes this is why we drive through the
night it is much safer
how much safer 50 50. oh what
[Music]
i'm adopted i'm not really indeed
you okay i had another family
a mother a brother i can still see their
faces
[Music]
i have to find my way back home
[Music]
how long are you on the train a couple
of days couple of days
it would take a lifetime to search all
the stations in india
[Music]
do you have any idea what it's like how
every day my real brother screams
my name
i always thought that i could keep this
family together
i need you syrup what if you do find
home and they're not even there
and you should keep searching
i don't have a choice
[Music]
what was she like beautiful
every night i imagine that i'm walking
those streets home
and i know every single step of the way
and a whisper in her ear
i'm here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you